or is it her no it was another girl she
was wearing a tank top but she's Brewing
type in tank top she's hot the one we're
looking for is hot are none of these
girls hot uh no no you're not the real
deal which is six seasons
[Music]
all right so there's this UK couple they
um are noticing in their house that
there's these like black dark patches
that are starting to appear on their
walls mold but it's not oh Shadows
steady move when I move it's weird there
are people shaped Shadows people shaped
but like I have to be standing in front
of the light
yeah it's only during the day it always
shows up after 6 p.m there's these
little
um dark patches that are starting to
like appear here and there and in the
floors
and they're like what's going on and
then also like a scent
but the scent is good what does it smell
like new car smells like the Aria yeah
soaps and then soap spill patches start
to get a little more saturated and they
start dripping a little bit it's still
smell good but it smells delicious what
strawberry just feel like you're lying
about the I'm not I'm definitely not
like it actually smells and then so the
one of the homeowners is actually crazy
enough to like test it no and it's yummy
what is it a Glade plug-in is leaking
from upstairs
is it is it food based I bet it's
something with food everything's food
come on baby something interesting
syrup they discovered that honey almost
their entire house oh my God
underneath the floors and on the other
sides of the ghosts this guy's good it's
turning into a giant beehive and they
didn't notice the
[Music]
buzzer
chocolate I know I said butter dude jump
shot just like just like Dallas
Mavericks last night
ah
wow can you smell that whoa can you
smell that and then he started look at
all that stuff man you gotta smoke them
out dude
look at that
everywhere
they gotta [__] burn that whole house
down now
oh
my God
the UK is kind of wild so the crazy
thing is
the crazy thing is that they pulled back
like that's under the carpet they've
already pulled the carpet back but what
happened was when they first pulled the
carpet back just a ton of maggots came
out because it's not the kind of beehive
you think it is it's an old hive oh so
it just left over it's left over here oh
that's why they didn't have bees
everywhere so no Beast so it's like an
old Hive that they didn't know about and
then because it it uh it was so old like
all the you know the leftover nasty
honey started like dripping down so you
can't actually eat any of the honey it's
gone bad like it's like the world's
biggest beehive of all time the whole
time I don't know I don't know if it's
the biggest so what happened is they
didn't that why you were asking about
the bees they're uh what did end up
happening was after they found it they
were gonna like reassess how to get rid
of it but the next day the room was
filled with bees because uh because if
they were uncovering all these like
different like pieces of Hive bees
discovered that they could raid the old
nest like other bees so they had the I
guess there's a another type of bee that
takes old Hive material homeless bees
it's a flip they're flipping the bead
bees are taking over the old storage
containers like Storage Wars yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'd watch it
yeah
but they but they're bees though yeah
they're bees yeah they started to um but
they would just they wouldn't bother
anybody because they're not focused on
stinging anybody like they have a
mission right so they'll fly in and
they'll just gather as much stuff as
they can and go out so it's almost like
they were just circulating in and out so
they just gotta wait a couple of months
and then the house is going to be all
cleared up oh they're gonna take the
materials to make a hive elsewhere or
they're gonna make a hive there yeah
well they're just taking leftover stuff
they're not gonna make the hive there
they're just taking it away so yeah
they're like La homeless like taking all
the Copper from the old house yeah yeah
right it was a good service yeah it's
crazy because they they tried to get a
quote on like how much it would be to
like take all this stuff out and and uh
it would have cost 10 grand oh for all
the dude nah [__] that I got a better
way go to the zoo grab two bears let
them loose in your house for a week
don't [__] eat all that [__] oh and
they'll even redo the drywall yeah right
let's go now the price is at 30. and
then your neighbors are like Hey we're
[__] suing you like our dog got eaten
by a bear
covered in Honey dude you guys suck and
we're suing you and [__] you so they
decided instead to just get a bunch of
friends together to do it and they ended
up clearing the whole thing out four
weeks wow four weeks is a lot of time
yeah I mean it's a lot of hives should
have got a pet bear four weeks I told
you two guys two bears two weeks that's
all I need they said that uh they ended
up filling 20 massive like bit like
garbage bin size things uh full of just
honey like old nasty honey they should
have just started a candle business
there's so much free wax
melted down these people aren't
businessmen all right smart yeah they're
not really that smart not resourceful is
that a British thing they're not as good
as like people who can sit in the room
and just pitch things and they don't
have to be held accountable yeah oh also
they really all the newbies that were
coming through they also didn't want to
harm any of them so they had to do it
really like carefully how lame I mean
they don't want to harm the bees they're
[__] they don't do those things that's
what you say to the news wait what did
they say how long it was there because
honey doesn't usually expire it takes
a decade or so I don't know they said it
was it was inedible that it's like I
think because why did they eat it and
they got food poisoning no they said
that
um so like some a moths had attacked the
the old hives so if it's if it's like
contaminated yeah it's like taken over
by another occupant [__] yeah right
yeah all kinds of other bugs are down
there like that's probably bad the
maggots yeah yeah yeah you know some
some of the Hipster would buy it they
don't know how to filter it correctly
though yeah these guys are kind of
idiots dude
all the answers like they're sitting on
a gold mine give me a coffee filter I'll
solve it and some water and some hot
water that's all I need
two bears coffee filter I got it and
your plan seems pretty cheap too how do
you keep from getting stung when you're
handling bees
oh dude uh smoke smoke yeah that's what
they use just you smoke a cigarette the
whole time we watch the same [__] B
videos on YouTube let's go because yeah
I know about the smoke yeah find the
queen and relocate the queen and the
hive will just follow her I thought job
was gonna be like we gotta get 30
Japanese hornets and then we let them
lose
they'll kill all of them and then they
start multiplying yeah they said it's
called Marigold gloves you ever heard of
Marigold gloves they don't like butter
they can't sting through Marigold gloves
oh do you remember watching that hot bee
like Bee Movie girl no there was like a
hot ass girl that would just like go to
homes that have like bee problems and
she would make YouTube videos I think
she passed away or something like that
but she would just be no protection just
like a smoke [__] canister got
incense or something in there
yeah and then just she would just be
like okay B and then she would grab the
The Beehive get it out of the way yeah
you're in love Halloween costume for
some reason I love watching B videos
yeah and people who like in their own
backyard they have like a like a bee kid
or whatever and they [__] get enter
they integrate their bees and then like
ah man I'm a nerd huh and they don't
they don't wear the protective gear they
don't no they got this thing it looks
like a um it looks like the [__]
thing you put water in yeah like you
know like a kettle yeah no like the
thing you water plants with oh yeah yeah
like water in their bees or something
yeah yeah is it her
okay if it's not her then is it her
or is it her no it was another gross she
was wearing a tank top but she's Brewing
type in tank top she's hot the one we're
looking for is hot are none of these
girls hot uh no no you're not the real
deal
she was like a bee
she was like a bee uh what do you call
it like a like a conservationist but
also I know this isn't her but it really
matches what you just told me
I think she hunts bees with these is
what it is
that's her oh that's her Double D's bees
no man that's not her either no she's
not Russian there's a lot of hot girls
who are being cute
because we can't find them maybe it's
not nerdy maybe it's kind of cool
actually I think I was wrong about
beekeeping bro that's the bee's knees
man no I watched a guy have to like you
have to like destroy this Colony that he
had because it got too aggressive and it
was like [__] up his other bee
colonies so how does he destroy it set
on fire killed him really he like filled
it up with water or some [__]
that's not the ones I saw there's even
obese hey keep it up though let's keep
it going that's not the ones I saw
there's too many of them they're great
it's YouTube
YouTube
Type in beautiful be cute beautiful
beach it was that first girl no it's not
I've seen the blonde chick that's the
one there's no other one there's no
brunettes huh B look at redhead look at
bread dude if Joe finds it first
I don't know I think you're gonna end up
on that same girl that I showed you with
the side swept hair if it's not then
that's what do you call those like bee
extinguishers no extinguishers beekeeper
or be Handler it's a beekeeper yeah it
needs a b Handler bee removal backyard
shed oh it is that girl oh she was on
[__] Joe Rogan I thought she was
brunette yeah it's this chick yeah
that's her what is hot oh this is what I
was thinking about
the sun was making her blonde hair look
she is brunette but it's her room okay
she looks hotter in motion oh she's a
dirty blonde yeah okay yeah
it's the glasses she's like a smart cute
nurse like an April O'Neil kind of deal
all right she's a cute nerd man that's
pretty cool but beekeeping became pretty
like uh trendy did you guys realize
you're trying to save the bees did you I
don't know if you guys knew that yeah
that's why I got into B videos not
because of the girl but because like I
was like if the whole issue of like we
can't get Farming and all that stuff
done because there's not enough bees and
then the human population is gonna die
yeah and what we all need to do is just
have a bee farm in our backyard yeah and
I was like where can I get a bee farm
and that's when I started going down the
rabbit hole oh yeah
do you guys don't you guys scare the
bees a little bit I'm sure have you been
stung by a bee once I've never been
stung back I got some of my whole nest
of yellow jackets one time for real like
my girl like that movie I think that
movie [__] me up actually are yellow
jackets bees or Hornets Hornets
it was wild though I'm like coming out
of my neck and [__] and I was running
what did you do [__] kick it or
something I was following this one
that's really pretty and I had just gone
to the dollar store and I got like a
little butterfly net and like I was like
probably like 21. and then and then like
you know I was following this really
pretty one right it was like it was like
almost like you look at those fish that
are like neon betas it was like that it
was like beautiful and she was like it
was like glittering in the sun I was
like oh I'm gonna get that one that's
gonna look real good in a jar on my desk
and so I was going after and then she
went all the way back to the nest and
then I didn't know there's a nest there
and I was like oh [__] and then they
were just coming at me it was like
swarming did you have a [__] Pond you
could jump into and like hide no
nobody's water damn maybe he's the queen
it was I think it was wow if you mess
with the queen but I don't know anything
about yellow jacket that's the queen you
get the horns dude
[Music]
foreign